[Música]
momento de hablar de economía aquí en
directo América me acompaña en el
estudio Jorge Hurtado Jorge muy buenas
noches comenzamos hablando de esas
declaraciones de la directora del fondo
monetario internacional sobre las
medidas que han adoptado en el Reino
Unido que dijo Bueno la funcionaria
básicamente reprendió a los funcionarios
británicos por este nuevo plan que
incluye muchos recortes la funcionalidad
dijo el ministro de finanzas y al jefe
del Banco Central de ese país que sus
políticas no deben ser contradictorias
la declaraciones se dan en el marco de
las reuniones anuales del fondo
monetario internacional y el Banco
Mundial en Washington ahí yo lleva se
refirió al controversial mini
presupuesto de Reino Unido que incluye
un aumento del gasto y recortes de
impuestos que según analistas no van en
la dirección de la lucha contra la
inflación y el impacto de la guerra en
Ucrania la funcionaria recordó que el
mundo tiene ahora un 25% de probabilidad
de recesión esto por el aumento de la
inflación la subida de los tipos de
interés y la subida de los precios de la
energía provocadas por la la funcionaria
invitó a los bancos centrales a seguir
endureciendo su política monetaria
porque la inflación parece no ceder
escuchemos
nuestro mensaje a todo el mundo no se lo
ha Reino Unido a todo el mundo en este
momento
la política fiscal no te beso acabar la
política monetaria porque si lo hace
entonces la tarea de la política
monetaria se hace solo más difícil y se
traduce en la necesidad de un aumento a
un mayor de las tasas y el
endurecimiento de las condiciones
financieras
Así que no prolongan el dolor asegúrese
de que las acciones sean coherentes y
consistentes
pasamos ahora a hablar de túnez porque
allí continúan las largas filas para
conseguir combustible y esto agrava la
crisis económica de este país
norafricano bueno las autoridades allí
insisten que el suministro está de lo
más normal posible y inclusive culpan a
los con por ir a hacer estas largas
filas a la gasolineras según las
autoridades hay combustible para los
próximos 10 días y el principal problema
de escasez se debe a que los proveedores
solo entregan el producto exceptuando el
pago contra entrega y en efectivo sin
crédito alguno túnez se enfrenta a la
escasez de productos subvencionados como
la harina y el aceite de cocina que son
importados por el estado y distribuidos
a precios inferiores a los del mercado
convencional el país está en
conversaciones ya con el fondo monetario
internacional para obtener un préstamo
por al menos dos mil millones de dólares
para tratar de enfrentar esta crisis
económica la prolongada crisis se ha
agudizado en los últimos meses y con
escasez de productos básicos y una
inflación anual que ronda ya el 9%. y
pasemos a hablar de Pepsi porque a pesar
de la inflación global esta compañía
mejoró sus previsiones para este año
Como lo hicieron bueno pepsico cerró el
trimestre ganando 2700 dos millones de
dólares entre junio y septiembre de este
año un 21% más respecto al año pasado la
multinacional de alimentos y bebidas
también aumentó su facturación en un 9%
hasta los 21.900 millones de dólares el
beneficio por acción fue de 1,97 dólares
o 0,13 dólares por encima de los 184 que
habían estimado los analistas buena
parte de esto es por la subida de los
precios que la multinacional viene
realizando un dato curioso Santiago es
que el mejor desempeño de esta compañía
a nivel global se realizó en
Latinoamérica México Brasil Colombia y
Argentina impulsaron este crecimiento la
gaseosas y los Doritos no salen de la
dieta latinoamericana pese al alta
inflación usted los consume a veces
vamos ahora a Chile porque el congreso
de ese país aprobó la ley fintech en qué
consiste Entonces esta iniciativa bueno
empecemos aclarando que son la fintage
que es un nuevo sector de empresas que
usan tecnología para automatizar los
servicios y los procesos financieros
también es conocida como la tecnología
financiera en Chile la ley Busca
fomentar la competencia así como
Establecer un marco regulatorio para
para todas aquellas empresas que hoy
prestan servicios financieros Ahora sólo
falta la firma del presidente Gabriel
borich para su total aprobación las
fintech ahora serán reguladas ahí por la
comisión para el mercado financiero y es
importante porque pese a la gran
adopción en Latinoamérica Hay pocas
regulaciones o pocas leyes que están
trabajando respecto a esta industria
Claro que sí Jorge pasamos de chile nos
vamos hasta México porque allí el Banco
Central de este país reconoce que la
inflación va a ser de mayor magnitud y
también se va a prolongar más tiempo de
lo esperado así lo muestra la última
minuta de su encuentro del 29 de
septiembre cuando elevó la tasa de
interés al 9,25% el mayor nivel de su
historia hasta el año pasado para el
banco mexicano la inflación era
transitoria pero se mantuvo en el 8,7%
anual en septiembre su nivel más alto en
los últimos 22 años el banco prevé ahora
que la inflación general promedio un
8,6% anual en el último trimestre del
2022 tras la expectativa anterior del
8,1% Y esperan que la económica en el
tercer trimestre de 2022 también se
desacelera en ese país Jorge cifra del
día sorprendanos hoy Bueno la cifra es
de entre 160 y 200 millones de dólares a
eso ascendieron las pérdidas provocadas
por el huracán Julia en Nicaragua según
el gobierno el huracán golpeó
Centroamérica en categoría 1 el fin de
semana y solamente en Nicaragua afectó
15 mil viviendas de las cuales 700
fueron totalmente destruidas lamentable
el cambio climático haciendo estragos
allí en Centroamérica Muchas gracias
Jorge por esta actualización de las
noticias del mundo económico a
continuación en directo América ya viene
el debate